Bill Duke, Actor/Filmmaker/Author:  You know something, you know you done f'ed up right?
no no no no nothing nothing you know you
You know you done f'ed up right?
I had a martial arts teacher
once and give us lessons in terms of say
teacher said you know if a man wants to
fight you run away from him as hard and
fast as you can
he said but if he runs after you and he
catches you make sure he never chase you
again in 1984 I mean you're not allowed
to do anything without the permission of
the thought police and they determine
the reality they create this war that's
not living awareness happening at all
they have these soldiers marching and
all this stuff and that you're not
allowed to have a relationship without
their permission
can't just fall in love yet there let me
go through them so Richard Burton is the
head of the thought police and John
great actor John forgot his name he is a
citizen and he miss young girl fall in
love they kept meeting secretly at his
place in her place and running away and
running one day that thought
caught but I thought police and
helicopters coming the soldiers come in
and kept available and take them to the
thought police headquarters and John the
actor  was lying on the table
I thought police headquarters and
there's a spotlight on the table he's
lying there naked with his hands tied
and his feet tied and symmetrical force
comes with it to the table with a switch
that if you trying to switch on it just
electrocute you and there's water coming
down
it's a guy near the button in Richard
Burton is sitting there in Dallas I'm so
sorry I was wrong I did I did the wrong
thing I apologize I never should have
ever ever ever seen her and then it
image and Britney says well you know she
said that you started it he said well I
don't I don't know I just see this okay
and he says I'll never do it again
please forgive me free trust so he says
to Jesus how many things am i holding up
John says for which a Briton Nauset a
guy with the button when I do wrong what
do they what's wrong
how many fingers am i holding up for
what I do wrong how many fingers am i
holding up
I don't know I don't know better how
many fingers am i holding up
three three
I'm holding up as many fingers as I tell
you yes I'm holding up you got nothing
dude your eyes nothing dude your
intellect or your mind
I say it's three fingers how many are
they
three three alternative fact is in three
an alternate effect you won't believe
what we tell you to believe nothing to
do with your perspective at all okay not
me they'll only think I'm crazy
I don't get it done I can't sleep now
I'm gonna how tired I know if I don't
get it done my work that day I can't
sleep so I'm worried about it the next
day and okay how many hundred so I have
to get it you know just because it's in
and so I meditate and the meditation
helps me I see working been working
harder than me I can't imagine that but
if I do surprise me to work harder I
mean good is not good enough and great
it's not good enough excellence
excellence your names on it and even if
you didn't have the budget you needed
you gotta take what you have and do the
best you can but you're given you said
to make one may look like 20 you got to
do it and takes work
and sleep is not something you do we
always like this
I had a parents who taught me ethics
that I didn't know they were teaching at
the time I was very very young and my
father wants to say to my sister and I
bill and Evonne always remember this
you're no better than anybody else but
nobody else is better than you and they
said never ask anybody for anything go
get it
my father worked three jobs mother
worked two seven days a week sometimes
and they wouldn't take welfare or social
assistance they were too proud so I was
at a low point in New York City one time
and almost homeless and I literally was
getting high all the time on different
things and I was on the street I had my
hand out I was begging for money and
this older lady came by one day and she
looked at missing man crafts changed
she looked at me she walked by I thought
she was gone so I asked the next person
I thought little tap on my back the same
old lady I said yes ma'am we got change
she thought that my face she she said
son do your mama know y'all here doing
this
I said no man just shook your head just
walked away then give me a dime I turned
around I sit on the steps and never beg
for money again you still see her face
yes oh yes I turned then look likes of
what I walked her she walked two blocks
and took a left and I watched her change
my wife reminding him my parents told me
and I got a college education and I had
a master's degree and blablabla my
mother and father with a second and
third grade and they never asked anybody
for anything I had to carry that legacy
on change my life
family wise relationship wise never been
married
it's I've been very selfish and the
women in my life have hated that because
of my work ethic I try not to pick my
work home but next day I'm gonna go
prepared I want to I want to be able to
so okay let's have a few moments of
camaraderie and whatever okay great I go
work on the script and that's the most
that's not the most comforting of things
in a relationship
because we owe a each other the
attention that each other needs and I
voice struggled with that I always have
from the relationships I might and the
other thing it sounds crazy but being a
black man in this business I felt they
always had to be better not as good but
better because as good it's not good
enough it's always paranoid I could be
super duper duper super prepared I have
to you know so I'm speaking for more
than myself as an individual I'm
speaking for culture because we're
judged like that you know oh I didn't
know there was gonna be that good cause
he's black
you see he's a big guy you know never
want to be a B never want to be an 8a
plus plus it takes I almost think much
when I work it's always in my mind I
can't explain it assistant and the stuff
I shot the day before I know I know I
could have done it better if I had few
more hours I just want to be better I
want to be my legacy that it's excellent
it's something that I gave a thousand
percent
but I'm it's crazy too because you know
it's I could always be better you know
it's it so it could be different but
it's kind of like a little neurotic type
deal but it's Who I am as a creative
person well the system is set up for the
youth and they assume that whatever
older ones of us
have survived and then wizardmon
knows that we have is irrelevant I just
had him gonna build Danny heads and say
good luck when I was a young man there
was a hope there was a saying I never
forgot it and it was when I was a young
man I thought my father to be a fool now
that I have grown older oh how wise he
has become it's when you're young you
think you know every damn thing until
life smashes you in the face with the
truth of its indifference toward you and
all those dumb people that are you think
are older and you don't listen to I want
you to get a couple of scars you'll see
how stupid they really are it's gonna be
scarred first you know because I was
talking and they don't know nothing your
generations in the past but when you get
crushed and by crushed I don't mean by
not being successful ask what the cost
today of being successful is it's coming
out so you have success but you paid for
it
and so with that success comes shame
because she wanted the success more than
your self-respect you notice all these
people coming out now and saying
this is the price I paid and I've been
this miserable for all these years I
thank God I can say me too
and it took something off of me
can you imagine being successful knowing
the price you paid and choking on it for
the rest of your life
hey everybody I'm just fine I'm just I'm
great and I don't care about what I had
to do except my sleep at night I can't
sleep at night yeah well I was young I
thought that wisdom was when we knew
everything but for so much that you've
now figured out what it's really about
then I started studying quantum physics
and other things and astrology and
astronomy and other thing is that for
example not only have they not
discovered well how many planets they
are don't even know how many galaxies
there are that dark space that they're
going into now and the thing that I
realize now that I'm 74 be 75 this month
is to never ever stop asking why that's
true wisdom to understand how limited
our pea brain is you know Albert
Einstein spoke on it you know people
think I'm wise no I'm not why they say
just like
I'm always wondering I'm always
exploring I'm always thinking I'm always
trying to get more information because
it gives you a recognition of who you
really are compared to the size of this
you eat outside at night to the beach
you lie down look at the sky
there's no into it and you think of
yourself within that context it's not
that we don't have relevance it but
comparatively speaking
we are just no that's too big kind of
campus we're in there someplace
but our egos tell us through everything
and there is nothing beyond and all that
garbage until something catastrophic
happens and it make us question I don't
wait for the catastrophic I question
every day someone tells me this is
affect okay let me get back to you on
that I love Google
I don't like Wikipedia at all it's not
like a PDA you know they're young people
doing research papers on Wikipedia but
when I google things and go back to
multiple research points and find out
how many different opinions there are
about the same thing and then I have to
think about it that that expands my
brain like that makes me wrong I never
thought of it that way that's it that's
exciting to me but sitting back like
this old wise person who
I figured it all out that's a lot crap I
don't hear that from anybody not that
you have to not have information that
could help me in terms of talking to you
because you're humble enough to
recognize my humanity as I'm humble
enough to recognize yours that's a
different situation because you may know
some things I don't know and I want to
hear those things so I can start
thinking but if you're looking down at
me from this place of authority or you
know when my sister and I were children
there are two people we were told to
never question your Minister and your
doctor well today those are the people
that question most because you're gonna
tell me what to believe
you're giving me your opinion of my life
I'm getting other opinions you know put
them all together
and I'll make the decision not you make
the decision for me because I'm
responsible for my life
not you I appreciate your input I'm
gonna ask five other people like you to
give me your input to don't have oh okay
make a decision I was one of the first
black directors in TV in Hollywood
before me it was Michael Schultz like
Stan Lathan and recapping a junior
what to have that opportunity I went
through a walk I give an example of
things and I this is my book I was the
first black to return doubt was ever and
I was so happy I suppose it was a top
hit show on TV I've done a good job with
nice landing and other shows that Falcon
Crest and other shows they said ok give
you a shot come up to the gate runner
brother Studios roll down the window
look at the security guard before I
could say a word that security guard
says up who are you delivering for I
said no no no I'm not delivering for
anybody
I'm just like director on Dallas and I'm
here early because I want to be it's
like this one plug to the side I'm
always early so I pull over to the side
and it's like it's will be at 9 o'clock
it's 8:30 that was eight 4850 compliment
blow and I say kiss on the phone he
calls update office and let the Remi
back in the phone looked over at me back
on the phone
what's the phone and say I'm you raised
like this yes
that's my first day what year was this
late 70s early 80s in Los Angeles oh
yeah I buy the team says one day I was
doing um thought wouldn't crest go to my
motorhome I munching my hand walk by
train back trade now my city
okay guys man up you got something to
say to me it's it to my face
what are you talking about sir
I heard what somebody said somebody call
me tell me stand up god you're the
director of the fun would never say that
we talking about you some mistake I
think that you misheard us get my tray
dead around walking to a motor home I'm
gonna say to Falcon Crest one day we're
up in Napa Valley and I'm filming and
first ad we're filming in a restaurant
it's a practical location so we're there
you know just to shoot and he's supposed
to be quiet in the kitchen but they're
gonna be told were shooting him so the
first ad very arrogant guy we start
shooting had to cut a third time because
there's noise in the kitchen I say cut
say hey man there's noise and the kids
was the calm down he said he says to me
and I'm quoting in front of the cast in
the crew if you want him to be quiet go
back there and tell him your own damn
self
but that time I really had it
sorry threw down my head sitting I was
pushing toward a guy in jail I mean
grabbed me by my arm she looked me in my
face she said took a deep breath my
director's chair pon my headset back on
time for lunch came back she had fired
him she apologized for him see what I'm
saying there are people who want you to
fail but there are great people like
Jane Wyman I want you to succeed and
David Jacobs gave me several more
chances at Knott's landing and Larry
Hagman at Dallas my first did that show
first black director on Dallas who said
to me nice to meet you young man we're
gonna get along real fine as long as you
have me out every day by 3:30 I
guarantee you every day you'll be up to
3:30 and he come back and do more and
more shows I can tell you stories of
people who there's some great people in
this industry I mean when I say great I
mean they don't have to give you a shot
because they're good human beings and
they see beyond your color to your
humanity and your ability that they do
something then that they don't do it
loud they do it because they're good
people and if you deserve it they give
it to you they give you the shot because
they gave you that chance you do
more than you better than you could ever
do cuz yo that to them and yourself
there's some damn good people in this
industry when I came along I met a few
of them that changed my life I mean but
that's been a you know to be very honest
with you and I listen my biography I
grew up as a racist I hated alway people
because of slavery and segregation so my
father and mother go through I just
hated wait wait just and I'd go for the
angry young black man and that was tall
and awkward I didn't talk much and I
wrote journals and stuff and he's to
billing people I'll never forget who
changed my life mrs. Jean Walker English
teacher very stoic and like just walking
in the class she told me nine times
that's write in my journal when she was
teaching I just ignored her this vase
it's white woman
one day she says Duke stay here after
class just give me that book I said what
the gem will give it to me someone give
me anything she said if you don't give
me the journal I'll fail you in the
class and you can't pass to the general
at her pissed off I hated her come back
to class and next several weeks before a
spring break and looked at her like if I
could punch in your damn face man
spring break against come back to class
and the first day I'm going into class
she's a Duke come here
she gives me back my journal in this
book I said what is this
she says the national poetry contest
book so why do you let me give this to
me for she says look on page 49 she put
two my poetry poems in there anyone I
looked at her
did somebody I hated she had taken she
read my book my journal took the best
poems out and submitted them to a
national poetry contest I won I was
speechless and she knew I was speechless
she says there's nothing to say you're
good at what you do that changed my mind
I wasn't quite sure how to think about
race then because that never happened to
me and then I went to the Community
College and you know James Hall was the
Dean he was in the Navy and stuff and I
got a scholarship to Boston University
after Dutchess and I would tell but you
know it was difficult I got a
scholarship for in classes but I had to
work for room and board and food and
everything I was working seven days a
week exhausted and my grades weren't
that great and severus just going to the
arts college I decided I was gonna come
home to the Kip see I was going to stay
there for you you're quits bu and get a
job make money so I can save it for that
at IBM I went doing a summer of to visit
my friends at BU and I'm leaving dr.
hall
see hey Duke come here I gotta go talk
Duke come here come here
oh this guy's a boring ass white I can't
stand us I go into his office just to be
courteous he says how was he
I said okay how you doing dude okay he's
gonna Boston University right yeah well
I'm not I'm I'm going but I'm quitting
I'm staying McKenzie for a year and
gonna go back next year racism no you're
not
what are you talking about goes into his
vest pocket and he has an envelope to me
I said what he says he's open it in the
envelope it was a check of his own money
that paid for three years of my room and
board at West University I looked in
this man's white man's face I'm
supposing he doesn't say a word
look at each other I just thank you
he did not say I would put out his hand
and he said don't disappoint me
something happens to your racism after
that it's supposed to be your evil enemy
that's responsible for that negative in
your life and everything the devil of
the system the creature just gave me a
check to cover all of my expenses for
three years how do you hate that life
changing so I evolved you know in my
humanity to understand you cannot put a
blanket on any of everything it's all
about the human being the person the
individual who they really are behind
what their skin color is behind what
their words are their possession it
makes a little difference to know the
human if they respect you you respect
them simple arab chinese japanese jewish
white black green hispanic those topical
services that's a limited perception you
have the courage to engage people at
their level of humanity you're living at
it's easier to dismiss you because i see
you and i make assumptions I learned a
long time ago a s s you a me means it
makes an ass out of you and ass out of
me to us so and I was taught by those
two incidents it was incredible it
wasn't for those two people I wouldn't
probably be here today and never asked
for anything
all they say is to be your best that's a
reward
it's a truth
I'm setting up my monitor one day and he
says do you know no standing behind so
we talked about quitting Parks I said
get out of here I'm working it stop
playing just know Gordon Parks is
standing right behind he's one of my
heroes so I turn around and he says
don't get up don't get up he walks to me
he puts my hand on my his hand on my
shoulder and he says I never stopped
just looked at him in walked away I was
like you know given signs from the
universe you know and he was one of the
things that propelled me into continuing
because whenever you get depressed or
something you want to stop and then you
don't stop because of those people came
along and said don't you ever think of
stopping cuz I'm not gonna lie to you
there are times I wanted to give up
because it's like hard but then you
think of the people who loved you enough
to encourage you when you don't stop and
it's also your family's legacy could you
justify stopping a hell yeah is it
unfair yes if you don't fit into certain
boxes is it prejudice
yes are there people who don't like you
because of the color your skin yes
people don't like it because you're as
smart as him yes
so I don't know anybody who hasn't been
through pain I mean I know very wealthy
people and they're some of my friends of
mine but the size of the house and the
model of the car and the clothes that
you wear to mask your humanity and your
vulnerability is nothing real I mean you
can go into many many mansions and meet
misery in the face I mean so an actor
who's grown up in privilege it doesn't
mean that his father did not abuse it
does not mean his mother was not insane
it means the appearance of perfection
was there meditation saved my life I was
taught meditation chant some little
meditation TM by a good friend of mine I
was in a Broadway play and doing very
well but I gotten into drugs because
there are times in which the struggles
so difficult I was working and
challenges and that I just overlong and
it ended up at a point where in a
Broadway play and I'd be late to work I
they told me don't be late anymore and I
came read again and they said you're not
substitute but you're understand he's
going in and I got pissed off and dead
and my friend who saw this I'm said bill
you're sinking fast man you have to do
something but I said like what he says I
made like the drugs in hunka Hall but
try meditation say you want those people
what they're like
so it got worse and then she said try it
okay I mean I'll try ah here so I tried
it a couple of times it was interesting
but still taking drugs and alcohol and
then have to run on once she said I'll
tell you what I'll make a deal she said
if you meditate for six weeks without
taking any drugs or alcohol of any kind
and if you still want drugs and alcohol
after six weeks I'll buy your ailments
of anything you want I'm thinking oh boy
an Altima do you think I want are you
kidding me I'll take this debt which I
just know it's gonna work wasn't gonna
work first two weeks I felt something it
was like I don't know a little more ease
less stress second and third week more
focus
for than the fifth week the piece that I
was getting out of the drugs and alcohol
I was getting through meditation and
more I was getting a deeper sense of
something I can't even explain I haven't
touched drugs or alcohol since that day
and that was in 1974 became a TM teacher
it changed my life too I can't even tell
you it's it's hard to explain you know I
could tell you more stories about what
I've been through but that was God
working again to join me Chancellor
meditation I changed my life to for my
own salvation
I could lady who asked me to turn around
and miss Walker and dr. hall it's and
and I recognize these things that people
think I'm crazy because I say well God
is doing this oh whoa what should God
look like I don't know I know he's there
I trust because there are things that
have happened that I know I'll give you
another example it's in my book in 1984
I was working really hard and when your
agent says you're so tired you gotta
take a vacation the agent makes 10% what
you make when your agent tell you to
take a vacation you know that you're
exhausted so I took a vacation with the
why he because he had just get married
and don't we stay at the hotel there by
myself I just wanted to totally chill I
was there for a week as well there's
eight of two weeks I said I want to come
back to this place never been it's
beautiful so I got in the plane called
island hoppers it goes from one island
to another into a ground toy and they
get Michael
the island owner would have Maui from
the big island and it was a twin-engine
claim I was suddenly the plane said go
shaking so don't stop them talk to him
and it stops it was a Oh so laughing you
know let's go sit down sit down sit down
sit down sit down and buckle your seats
now usually in the movies when the
planes in trouble
the pilot says ladies and gentlemen be
calm be still over in control little bit
the pilot the powers doing help us Jesus
help us Mary help us lord help us Jesus
help us Mary help us Lord
the pilot look out the window I said no
he sure got close to the RAM we crash in
the water no water seem soft right when
you hit the water from that height well
bam bam it tore the bolts out of my seat
and threw me forward the scar is from
that happening and when that happened
this it's hard to explain but it's an
out-of-body experience something up
there look down and those sounds crazy
look down at me and my seat all the
people bleeding the pilot and everything
okay so this thing I can't explain what
it was it's peaceful just observing me
how it wakes up its face hit the
dashboard of the plane everybody else
get up Suzy did it this thing in my body
merged back together and they said Oh
cuz I don't swim
I said go I said it out loud you always
wanted to know how you're gonna die now
you know I just sat there waiting for
the water's coming up boom boom boom
Bloods coming up boom boom boom boom
power gets people out take them to the
wing hey you come on let's go let's go
let's go
I said I can't swim he says unbuckle
your seat okay I'm booked on my seat
take a life throw that out
I've thrown up put it on your head he
gives the instructions pull of course
when I got this shorter like five chords
I looked down and saw a thousand I kept
pulling and pulling and pulling and
pulling and pulling and pulling nothing
after he left their places come to the
wing I said I don't see this come to the
wing I got the wing I'm standing there
and they all paddled away cuz they old
family everything gotta go five or six
hundred feet away he says jump jump
undertow undertow I said I can't swim he
says jump I said to myself what day I'll
have to lose I'm gonna die anyway so I
jumped I forgot to tie to life don't
around my waist
cuz he had owned he had pull a cord as I
I passed them they blew up I've got
tired of my waist and with that once
twice third time I came up life I'm not
exaggerating life doughnuts here I put
it around my head like a little dog I do
like this then I reach them I recently
turned around this big mouth of water
swallows the plane and takes it if I
stayed on the wing I would have died
I'm telling us all the truth I'm telling
you in the water ten minute passes
people are moaning and groaning lady
says look boats planes boats planes my
thought is you know before you die
sharks Norden everything you have these
delusional thoughts and you think you
see things that's what she's doing right
so I said just boats planes boats planes
take this to Vegas you tell me the
chances of this family twice a year the
Hawaii Fire Department since its
emergency rescue teams out to do
practices and all different parts of the
ocean this day they were 1/2 nautical
miles away from us they saw our plane go
in there were there in minutes they took
everybody out the water wrapped us in
blankets asked if he okay
I started driving us back to shore I
said it's a pilot six foot two or three
Ichabod Crane blue eyes I could see his
face dark here with white streaks
through it sitting he's shivering I'm
shivering and I say to him sir I don't
wanna disturb you I said but I was in
shock you talked me through getting out
of the plane you talked me into jumping
off I talked me to puffing toward you
you saved my life and I want to I want
to thank you I cannot know what to say
he looks at me and he says I appreciate
you saying that he said I'm not on the
Catholic I believe in Jesus Christ he
says I don't know what you believe in he
said but don't thank me
thank that turns away from me
thus back of my face grabs my shoulder
and starts crying like a baby get back
to shore people are in shock because
planes that crash in that way don't have
survivors I have no way of explaining it
to say that that's one of the day that I
realized there are things happening in
this universe that are far beyond my
intellect far beyond my intellect and I
had my two masters degrees and I was so
smart I can't even tell you how much I
learned from that experience I pictures
on a wall of my conduct there of that
day the newspaper I saved it and just
framed it I never want to forget it it's
just so it shaped my life between those
experiences and meditation to shape my
life and made me understand that you
know imagine a story of a minute a
minister that's a friend of mine told me
he said bill you know one one day I
stood up in church and I said to my
congregation he said everybody that
wants to go to heaven
stand up dancing saying hallelujah a
whole church fifteen hundred people cut
up and they shouted for five to ten
minutes each column down
okay okay okay okay sit up
my second question everybody wants to
die stand up and sing hallelujah
I got my third question he said how are
the hell you gonna go to heaven if you
don't die see everybody wants to go to
hell but don't no damn body want to die
and dying what holly was about how do
you resurrect yourself after you're
smashed a couple of thousand times do
you buy a violin played a little
self-pity moments of having fear
everything is and how great you are and
how mean they are and that could go on
for thirty years forty years or do you
take the initiative to do something that
changes that it's like one or two
choices giving up or moving ahead the
volume of the energy higher low is
important but what's more important is
it focused
people with lower energy levels get
things done too because they're focused
toward higher Lynette Nietzsche levels a
lot of things right but they're not
focused a higher energy without a plan
without a vision without a stress
strategy
it's called frustration lower high
energy without focus is frustration I
may want it I see it over there but how
am I gonna get over there if it's a
mountain I think I need climbing boots
in a rope and stuff but I just want to
go over there
no but do you got it it's up but I want
to go over there I want to go over there
they're afraid to jump into the pond you
know it's like today it's a whole new
world in terms of this industry and say
there's a pond and the success range is
over there and a lot of folks just jump
in they can't swim but they the best
they can and get to the other side while
they're doing that some of us put our
arm in the water is it too cool
if it's too deep it's a too warm a lot
of waves out there by the time the pond
cools down and you start moving to the
other side and your little boat there
are signs put up other people who took
the chance and those signs say entry
fees you know why because they deserve
it we over their cowardly thinking they
didn't wait they jumped you know if they
were going to drown or not they they
didn't know anything they just know that
it's never over there I guess some that
so I don't have that I don't want to be
here anyway it takes that kind of desire
on my wall in my office have a picture
which is my favorite favorite picture
it's it's an ostrich or a swan who's
swallowing a frog and the Frog is
halfway down this one's throat for this
one problem the Frog has its hands are
brown this month squeezing and it smells
like and the title says never give up
you can be down their throat but as long
as you got your hands around that throat
can't swallow again I just finished
doing a film I would think I was in
Canada and acting in the film and I
rushed back and at the same day that I
came in I had to be on the set the
Hughes brothers and I just loved their
work I'm like oh they were I read the
script and I loved it it was only one
scene and it's like the way they set it
up got me immediately into the mood
because the room was dark except there
were like three spotlights one on you
the young boy one in the middle of the
table the gun was and one on myself and
everything else was in shadow and the
police had brought this young man into
this place to intimidate him into
telling the truth
and so he was sitting there really
nervous you know he thought he was
smarter than everybody in the in the
room
and so when I questioned him it was like
I first brought the gun in put on the
table and turned it toward him but said
to him you're not necessarily getting
out of here alive there's nothing you
can do about it
what are you gonna do we can all say
that she reached for the gun and we
defended ourselves in charge media sales
words we just won like that that was
that that said that said it when he saw
that it was like okay and we started
asking questions I have some questions
about was he there and he said no and he
said you left the beer here and you
bought the beer at this time you drank
the beer at this time and then he was I
saw his hands start shaking and then I
asked him the same question again and he
then the second time said a different
time and that's when I knew that I had
him and you know that little gang
thought they were so smart and we were
so stupid
it was a number it was a it was a
feeling of joy when I said to him you
know something nigga fucked up right no
no no no no no nothing you know you done
fucked up right yeah here's what's crazy
I was in Brussels Belgium around five or
six months ago acting in at full of
Nicolas Cage call Mandy right I'm
sitting in a restaurant eating food by
myself
this young building kid comes up to me
and says you choose me sir but you know
you don't fucked up right
I laughed so hard but no matter what
country I go to I mean I've made a lot
of films as an actor and director and
the line that said to me the most around
the world no matter what city I cook
over and you know something there are
young kids that's what's amazing to me
they've all seen that picture I don't
know how they see it but they see it leo
I'll repeat that line and older people
too so yes it's it's it's interesting
how has that impacted your life I'm sure
it's got to feel good that people know
your work yes at the same time maybe
you're surprised that they're young kids
that are seeing this film and from all
walks of life what does that mitt do to
someone what it means you did a good job
because you impacted them in that way
you also wish there is more than shit
they remember you for than just that
line but you know you're a preach it
till of the fact that they've seen your
work and they appreciate what you've
done and that it's always good you know
because I'm very self-critical in my
work and so when someone affirms that
what I've done it impacted them that's
that's a very rewarding it's very order
they don't have to be kind they don't
have to come up to you they don't have
to what they do at a certain age you
think you'd think you've been forgotten
about and you haven't that's rewarding
also especially when young people do it
in different countries there was not one
piece of distribution in place when we
put our money together to make dark
girls
we were passionate about this topic
because both of us met my co partner
Chambery we had are both dark-skinned
black men who have faced the prejudice
of being dark complected in her own
community and we saw members of our
family little girls from five six seven
eight nine ten years old going through
this pain being called monkey ape darkie
gorilla face ugly and asking their
mothers can they be bleached lighter
because they were ugly and the parents
trying to say so he said no let's see
what happens so we made the film then we
cut a trailer the trailer online and I
got 2.3 million global hits and we said
we have something we have something so
let's see if we can get a touring
company - he did we got a touring
company tourists around and we're
country and different parts of the world
and the success was really great we
still having the distribution and so we
said okay let's get a broker maybe a
Booker and maybe the Booker can have
some screenings well how much is it
gonna cost us okay as we're going into
the costs for the Booker to maybe say
five or six a a means these theaters or
something
man between the booking and the
promotion and careful we're dry good run
until film fizzles and so on I get a
call on the phone
Oprah Winfrey's interested in a you guys
screening the film for her okay sent it
to Scott over there
it's got looked at it brought it to
Oprah's office saw it and he said what's
your lawyers name and what's that
happiness it was a I'm not gonna lie man
it was a paint it was painful man some
days you wanted to say forget it and
give up what about it was painful and
what was the timeframe are we talking
about year and a half I mean you're
talking about you know your your your
bank account is dry and you got bills to
pay and your accountants pissed at you
to the degree of your you really are
something's wrong with you you spent
this money for your mortgage this year
and where is that gonna come from you're
crazy you're and you start thinking
crazy and then divine intervention it
what if you want to call it says you're
you're doing something that we want you
to do so we're gonna help you when that
happens it's like first time you take a
deep breath in a long time
but you can't give up we just it's the
it's it's it's the blessing and curse of
this industry you know you it's it's a
blessing and a curse I mean you keep
going because you're passionate you're
gonna get it done you know but it's not
painless and then when someone sees what
you see and they have distribution and
they say it has value tears and I don't
mean the polite time Yunus the snotty
type you know that kind of stuff that
really just thankful the lady in the
Apollo Theater I showed the film and she
stood up she was older lady and she said
Oh with all the respect I thought the
film was great but why are you Aaron our
dirty laundry that's shameful I said man
with all due respect it's because it's
sticking up the house and she didn't
like what I said but I was being honest
because there's so many there's so much
in the American community but in the
black community in this nation there are
so many things that we are expecting to
be solved by someone else there's this
expectation of salvation you know
somebody on this horse or this this
train of gold is gonna come in and
they're gonna save us
I remember we waiting for Godot you know
great play could go down there he never
came
they have just left on rocks waiting and
I am trying to do my documentaries I
call them edutainment trying to say I'm
gonna contain you
here's information that if you apply it
to the problems that we face there's a
chance that we can have an impact in a
positive way but I cannot do that for
you
that's what not what I do I am a
filmmaker and what we're finding is
somehow that's not enough it could be
tyre I mean I could just live but you
know there's something that um I had
dinner at my house this was like a year
ago and my nine people were there and
the discussion was about in your
lifetime out of all the people you've
ever known what percentage of them ended
up doing what they wanted to do with
their lives that percentage which three
three percent so when I look at my good
fortune all I continue to go through and
I've been through but I am still doing
at my age what I want to do with my life
and I wake up every day and I want to do
more I do never want to retire no matter
what the pain has been I feel like I'm
blessed because most of my friends that
I grew up with are dead or if they're
not dead they retired from jobs they
hated that they did for 35 years or more
and they retire and they sit on the
porch and go on cruises and stuff which
is okay
they never enjoyed one day at work not
one day why do most people make that
choice I think security there's some
security and having you know two kids in
the house and the car working at a job
that gives you insurance for your family
vacations retirement guaranteed it
there's a certain security about having
that some people way happiness against
security for 90% of all security always
wins
Patil if you have kids because once you
have a child I mean it's your wife is
secondary to the needs of what you've
created in this world
but there's another side to it in that
if you wake up every morning and you
don't have security but you love waking
up you love going to work you love the
fights no matter how painful it is you
you will ok Goliath my stones not that
big but I see your damn eye man I see I
see right here man I'm not saying today
but you see this little I'm twirling I'm
twirling the stone you know it's taking
me longer than I thought you're going
down there's two books that I would
recommend to people one is by Steven
Pressfield it's called the war of art
it's one of the greatest books I've ever
read helped change my life the war of
art another one is by Seth Godin it's
called the dip in the dip talks about
people who are serious about whatever
they're doing they go go go then they
have a dip you know naive one of two
choices of getting out of that you know
you can continue doing what you're doing
or you can begin to learn from where
you've been and turn it into an
advantage so if you want to be an
actress for 20 years or 15 years and you
never really were able to get foot a
foothold or a great agent or whatever
you can either stop or you can say hmm
how can I use another way of getting to
where I want to go and today there's no
excuse I said webisodes
mobile TV games cell phone apps kids
made a feature film with two cell phones
I mean what are you waiting for
the thing is that we were caught in this
whole paradigm that I cannot do anything
without the permission of a system and
if you continue to think of it that way
you're right you're waiting for
permission but suppose you say I'm no
longer waiting for permission I'm going
to create my own opportunity and then be
perfect in the beginning but I'm going
to refine it I'm going to create
strategic alliances I'm an actor writer
but I know a starved a starving director
over there
that guy isn't worked in five years and
he's looking for something maybe and I
well I know a set designer who's
Carnivora
producer hasn't was fired four years ago
hasn't worked sentencing but that kind
of thinking it's in the book that stuff
Godin wrote called tribes he says stop
trying to do it by yourself stop trying
to do it by yourself you don't have to
you have one or two choices
I'm going to satisfy your needs and
ignore the truth of my own I'm gonna
satisfy my needs and they grow the truth
the relationships dates I tried this
once like like the person so much I
tried not taking a job and staying in
the house and watching the flowers grow
and doing all the things she liked and I
she was happy but there's the truth that
I I i realized something after a few
months of feeling resentment
and that eventually manifesting itself
so was it I was I was fulfilling the
desires
it wasn't happy because I was lacking
something I've always been a worker I
always wanted to work Oh work stimulates
me it gives me fulfilment it's not that
I need romantic fulfill make everybody
else I need love and caring like
everybody else but loving caring without
me feeling engaged in something I'm so
passionate about which is my work if I
gave that up I it's not good for a
relationship with me and it's in that
that's what that's what's so difficult
you know it's I think I spoil spoil my
goddaughter because it's like you know
since three we spent so much time
together and I helped raise her and
spoiled her and everything you know
because I don't think it was there
enough I just kept doing things things
things we worked it out of course but
it's like she's traveled around the
world in many places and everything and
that's all good but she was saying look
think we just sit down and just meditate
we just sit down and just talk yes I do
that
I got everybody saying we were safe 74
gonna be 75 February 26 I have to still
be working so Wallace am I gonna do
retire just you know just sit in the
porch in the beach watch the flowers
grow and and enjoy the air and so that's
the rest of my life huh
enjoying the flowers suppose I could
discover how the flowers are made
suppose I could discover where the sky
came from where I suppose I could
discover where air comes from and the
source of reality and film it
I mean I mean one of the my heroes of
discovery he's older than me or some
working freemen with his new network and
and this whole probably about God you
know who and where is God what is God
where I mean these amazing thinkers cuz
he plays those questions himself and he
just the his brilliance of going into
those topics and understanding God what
does that mean to cultures around the
world that's fascinating to me but he
still has an open mind he still wants to
learn and know that's inspiring I
watched last night Terry Bradshaw and
the boxer I forgot his name but so it's
probably called better late than never
and these four older men they're in
their 70s and some in their eighties and
well this one young guy the son I think
Terry brought show-cause with them
around the world and they visit places
they always want them visit before they
die but they do it together it's funny
it's inspiring it's powerful because
they don't stop they just know before I
I got a certain amount of time left I'm
gonna do everything everyone to do and
that there's something about that's
wonderful it's beautiful because they
don't say I'm retiring and I'm gonna lay
up and get it and just watch the birds
go by
they're flying the birds so it feels a
fly okay I love it
that's life a lot of my friends work at
jobs they hate for 35 years they work
every day but to be admired health
insurance car payments house note send
the kids to college all the dreams they
had they gave him up when they were 20
was they had children they retire and
there may be dead and five to nine years
it's not what I wanted
it's not what I want I hope I don't
probably die in a set you know something
you know I don't know I'm just saying
only God knows that but I mean I just
want to do something I wanted to do and
these days huh how was seeing Spielberg
and George Lucas and and Clint Eastwood
they don't stop I'm writing this book
for all the losers in the world for all
the people that have been told you
cannot do it you're a loser you're too
stupid you're too ugly or to a dummy or
to black or to whatever you're never
gonna make it
I've been called all those things and
worse
I'm writing this book because I want
children who are going through similar
things and never give up on themselves I
can get through it so can you
never never whether you're 5 or 100
never give up it's never too late you
determine your reality are there forces
that helps shape that context around you
of course there are I mean but what is
your responsibility because the
boogeyman's bigger than you you don't
you don't fight back you don't do
nothing you don't buy this toy you don't
do nothing you just talk about the size
of the book in the hand how long he's
been on your neck the color of the
boogeyman the boogeyman system or the
boogie Mans how can you say the order of
his breath you can describe every aspect
of the boogeyman for the rest of your
damn life or you can buy this tub now ya
ain't gonna kill with you buy this - but
toes are sensitive there's gonna be some
movement well he needs a little bit a
little bit but you're not gonna bite
well that's your definition of your
possibilities in life I can't bite
because the boogeyman so big and I'm so
weak goodbye shit sorry not me never
you gotta have my guess a couple of
bullets they better hit something that's
vital because they can remove them on
coming back never give up never and as I
feel needless to say to the people who
try to stop you and put you down there's
only one phrase that they deserve and
that is this - dumb as you look
my name is damn dumb as you look
we can keep talking I want you to know
something - dumb as you look
you know it's interesting once they see
that who Ortiz they know that you're not
playing checkers in a chess game you're
playing chess my mom was a both playing
chest let's play so I got some damn
moves - let's just play
don't tell me y'all gonna check a play I
am
that's why I feel within Churchill true
power is an individual's ability to move
from failure to failure with no loss of
enthusiasm anonymous aspire to inspire
before you expire anonymous if a man
does not seek humility humility will
seek the man I'm a final one anonymous
and your lifetime you will never see a
smaller package then the person wrapped
up in themselves
and I found each one of those to be true